hi I'm Jacob hacker I'm the director of
the institution for social and Policy
Studies at Yale I'm Casey King I'm the
executive director of the Yale Center
for analytical sciences and the two of
us are here to talk about an event that
we're hosting on November 29th it's at
four to six pm at luce hall it's
entitled the volatility economy Wall
Street main street in the middle class
now Casey and I actually thought up this
conference when we were on a bike ride
we were talking together about some of
the work that we've been doing I've been
doing a middle class economic insecurity
and its links what's happening on Wall
Street Casey's been doing work on
volatility in Wall Street and whether or
not some of the controls that the
markets have adopted like these circuit
breakers that stopped trading when
there's big volatility whether they
could do anything to make the the
markets better well anyway since we
started talking about it the markets
have gotten even more volatile than they
were when we were on that ride and we've
gotten a great panel together we've got
Joe Nocera a Wall Street I'm sorry Wall
Street columnist for the new york times
we have Frank Hathaway who's the Nasdaq
chief economist and we have the
legendary Bob Shiller the economics
professor here who predicted the major
crash of the bubble back in the early
2000s and predicted the housing market
bubbles end in late two thousand so he's
going to be speaking about what we can
what we can do and what's happening
right now in the market I'm going to be
talking a little bit about middle-class
economic and security and its links to
what's happening on Wall Street one of
the most interesting things that I've
been finding in my work is that even as
we've seen the overall economy get less
volatile in the 2000s in the last decade
we saw family incomes get much much more
unstable well in the last few years
we've seen family incomes get more
unstable even more unstable but the
markets go out of control so what are
the links between family income
instability and market instability now
that most Americans do their retirement
savings in the stock market what does it
mean that we see such volatile markets
today and and houses tied up with a huge
explosion of debt among families those
are some of the issues i'll be talking
about yeah I mean it's it proves it
suggests a really interesting discussion
for me free market when I think about
free market it's more than just an idea
for Americans it's really fundamental to
who we are as a people but but given the
volatility in the markets in the past
few years and the debacle of 2008 where
millions of jobs were lost and millions
of dollars people are looking more and
more to go to government to do something
to regulate an industry that seems to be
careening wildly and somewhat
irresponsibly out of control seems to be
driven by this rage of accumulation
without any notion of public service and
given this imperative one of the
questions I'm most fascinated by is what
what exactly should government
regulation look like can it be just can
it be effective cannon mitigate market
volatility and protect the lives of and
incomes and livelihoods of ordinary
Americans and I think this is a
fundamental question how do you how do
you reconcile a free market ideology
with the current calls for market
regulation and you're going to be
looking at the the viola tea that's
taking place and whether or not some of
those circuit breakers that kick in when
markets get out of whack whether they
can actually help yeah I mean that was
one of the first real substantial
government interventions was putting in
place these circuit breakers after may 6
2010 when a trillion dollars was lost in
a matter of minutes there was a
clamoring to do something and what was
done was these circuit breakers were put
in basically if the market dropped more
than ten percent over any five minute
period training stopped but was it
enough and so what my research partner
Michael Caine and I did was we looked at
24 billion trades leading up to that
flash crash to see if this action were
more symbolic than substantive I mean
with the with the underlying idea that
this policy and any policy that's put in
place any sort of government regulation
must be data-driven it can't just be
opinion driven we found we had some
pretty interesting
I won't quite give it away here because
I want people to attend the conference
and by all means come on out and and
there's going to be lots of data and
opinions on display at this conference
at luce hall on November 29th from four
to six pm the market is going up and
down come understand what's happening
and what it means for you and for our
society
you